so as we get into the final character is
part of our lead up to Deadpool kills
Deadpool we join now what I consider to
be probably one of the coolest
characters from Deadpool kills Deadpool
that is of course the story of head pool
or zombie Deadpool
so zombie Deadpool originates as we
would expect in the zombie universe but
with Marvel Zombies with volume one all
we know here is that Deadpool scene one
time and the only time we see him is
when he's one of the various I guess
superhero zombies in New York who is
among the group that attached the Silver
Surfer now we don't actually find out
what happens to his character later on
until we get into Marvel Zombies vol 3
now with Marvel Zombies vol 3 what we
know is that once the main I guess the
core group of Marvel Zombies the more
prominent members in vol 1 had taken off
into space to find more people to
consume that Wilson Fisk that the
kingpin had taken this time to solidify
a kingdom of sorts to solidify an empire
and the goal of Wilson Fisk was to
basically spread the zombie plague
throughout the throughout multiple
dimensions and so what he had done is he
had sent a Deadpool zombie Deadpool to
the Florida Everglades which again as we
discussed in our video about Howard the
Duck is the home of Swamp Thing I'm
sorry of Man Thing the home of the
interdimensional portal that leads to
virtually all other dimensions and so
what happened was that almost
immediately after a Deadpool had arrived
at this location he was attacked by
jennifer cail and in the process he was
thrown into a fan and his body was
destroyed leaving only his head now we
don't know exactly how it was things
transition between Deadpool or I guess
head pool from the zombie universe and
head pull in the earth-616 dimension all
we know is that somewhere along the line
presumably due to his body having been
thrown into the fan that his head was
most likely thrown into the portal and
as a result he ended up in the earth-616
continuity now what we also learned is
that armor has been monitoring this
entire situation and armor takes custody
of Deadpool now armor is a group that we
haven't really talked about yet of
course we've talked about shield being
the I guess the intelligence police type
agency that monitors threats on the
planet Earth we've talked about sword
the sentient world observation and
response department that is basically a
version of shield that deals with other
planets within the earth-616 continuity
armor deals with other dimensions it
deals with other dimensional threats and
so once they had realized a Deadpool
his head pool head was carrying a zombie
plague he was in turn captured by armor
yet he was able to escape yet again and
so what happens here is that head pool
was able to to become free with the
assistance of Simon Garth and Simon
Garth is a character that we could go
into here but for the most part he's not
a particularly important character in
fact he doesn't really speak that much
but what happens is we eventually pick
up with head pool and Simon Garth as
they're confronted by a person named
Black Talon this is where it was a Simon
Garth was taking head pool now what we
learn here is that black talent is
basically running a drug operation based
out of his own private island and so
what he intends to do here is
effectively sell head pool to the
highest bidder for somebody that would
choose to use a zombie plague at which
he's carrying as a basis for a I guess
bio weaponry but what happens is that
while he's being held in a cage he
begins to mock and lure one of the
guards towards him and when the guard
arrives he bites the guards hand and as
a result with the guard having had his
finger bitten off the guard turns into a
zombie and begins attacking the other
guards and so as a result what we find
here is that Simon Garth takes head pool
away and the two of them begin to make
their escape now eventually at the end
of Deadpool I'm sorry of a Marvel
Zombies vol 4 we find that Simon Garth
has basically said ahead pool astray
he's put him on a boat and sent him out
into the ocean and so we won't actually
find out what happened to this version
of Deadpool until we pick up with a
limited series Deadpool Merc with a
mouth so Deadpool work where the mouth
is a 12 issue limited series that was
published between 2009 and 2010 and what
this does is it chronicles the
adventures of Deadpool from the
earth-616 continuity and zombie head
pool as Deadpool from earth-616 tries to
return zombie head pool back to the
zombie universe but to also give them a
body again now the way the story
initially kicks off we don't really know
what's going on with regards to zombie
head pool all we know is that Deadpool
from the earth-616 continuity has been
tasked with tracking down some sort of
weapon at the request of aim which
exists in some unnamed island somewhere
now aim is a group that we haven't
really talked about much like armor but
aim is a group that is called advanced
idea
hanoks and the basis behind aim is to
effectively overthrow the world's
governments by using technological means
now they've also fought alongside Hydra
and even at one point in time they were
a I guess a subjugate of Hydra they
existed under Hydra but the fact remains
that once Deadpool arrives at this at
this island he's taken captive along
with I guess dr. Betty who's the woman
is assisting him the aim engineer and
the two of them are brought before head
pool which is worshipped as a God of
sorts among the indigenous people
now what head pool does is he begins to
sort of fill in the gaps between the end
of Marvel Zombies vol 4 and Merc with a
mouth and what he tells us here is that
when he had been set in the ocean by
Simon Garth that eventually he had
encountered some kind of underground
river and the underground river had led
him to where he is now where he was
discovered by these indigenous people in
a game was worshipped as a god and so
his goal here with deadpool arriving is
to effectively have Deadpool's head or i
guess have his arms and legs cut off and
in turn to basically use him as a body
for head pool so that head pool can
regrow all of his limbs and effectively
have his own body again but what happens
here is that almost immediately after
the arm of Deadpool is cut off that he
uses his other arm and begins to attack
the indigenous people as well as I guess
take head pool for his own now what head
pool does here is he basically turns the
tables on Deadpool in saying that his
entire goal here was to have Deadpool
free him so that he could be I guess he
could escape this captivity that he's
been living in and so as a result along
with Deadpool and Betty as well as Bob
the sidekick of Deadpool making I guess
I guess a few appearances from time to
time what ultimately happens is Deadpool
and head pool make their way throughout
the the Marvel multi-dimension in order
to try to find the zombie universe now
along the way we encounter different
versions of Deadpool for example we come
across the the Deadpool Kid which is
basically a spin on Billy the Kid
of course this version of Deadpool is
killed almost immediately by the
earth-616 Deadpool because of the fact
that he's just really sort of annoying
during Deadpool Merc with the mouth we
also come across Lady Deadpool we come
across these different versions of
Deadpool but ultimately we find that
eventually
dead
and an head pool we turn back to the
earth-616 continuity and things just
kind of go from there and so what this
does is this leads us directly into the
I guess the the Deadpool core
this leads us into the story that leads
up to Deadpool kills Deadpool so from
here what we do is we jump into Deadpool
core issue number four and what we find
is that much like Deadpool's initially I
guess ending with regards to Deadpool
and the zombie universe what we find is
that he's basically been sent out to sea
here and so what happens is that we pick
up with this character whereby he's
discovered by a group of sailors now
these sailors seem to work for some kind
of a doctor or some kind of a henchman
and so as a result they recover the head
of head pool and then they take him back
to the island now once we arrive back at
the island we learned that the doctor on
this island is I guess engaging in two
different activities the first is that
he desires to basically collect skulls -
more or less using as trophies as a way
to demonstrate just how capable of a
hunter he is but he's also an
experimenter in the realm of science and
so what he wants to do is basically use
the the head of zombie Deadpool as a way
to progress his own science and so what
he does is he attaches a flying beanie
to the head of a head pool basically
giving head pool the ability to fly
around and so as a result what we don't
really know whether what basis this is
done while we don't really know how it
is that a head pool is able to fly on
his own the fact is it doesn't matter
because it's a Deadpool comics so what
happens here is we pick up with normal
Deadpool from earth-616 s he lands on
this island and once he arrives of this
island he begins hunting around for the
inhabitants and when he finds them he
also finds the daughter of the doctor
and the daughter of the doctor seems to
be waiting on her husband Alfonso to
return and so when when Deadpool arrives
and he sees her she believes he's
Alfonso and immediately demands that he
take her in a in a very I guess intimate
way and so as a result Deadpool's
immediately on board with this as would
anyone and so what we do here is we jump
to Deadpool as he's killing these
various men I guess these various
soldiers of the doctor and as a result
zombie head pool sees Deadpool on the
security cameras and so what he does is
he basically escapes away from the
doctor and then begins to pursue head
boy I'm sorry Deadpool
he's with this woman and so as a result
he calls Deadpool out Deadpool joins him
and the two of them retreat back to the
remaining Deadpool core which of course
is composed of kid pool dog pool and
Lady Deadpool with the two characters
Deadpool from earth-616 and zombie head
pool being added to their ranks now from
here what we're going to do is we're
going to bring this portion of the I
guess the prelude or the lead up to a
close and what we're going to find and
Deadpool kills Deadpool is we're going
to be introduced to an army of other
Deadpool's we're going to learn about so
many other Deadpool some of which we
won't get any history of some of which
we'll see only once and then of course
we'll also see quite possibly the most
powerful Deadpool to have ever existed
in the form of panda pool with that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly